what i'm trying to do is talk to you
guys about a very serious issue that's
affecting uh women's rights yes
free speech
i'm about free speech yeah yeah so what
do you guys think how would you solve it
i don't know that's what we're trying to
figure out right well my original
proposition i still think holds up which
is illegal everywhere except new york
city okay good for economy
oh so you go for like a little abortion
vacation gambling in vegas bro that's
what it is
travel take a vacation
i think it's kind of foolproof yeah but
what about the women who can't afford to
travel to new york what about women that
can't afford to travel to vegas and
gamble bro that's not everyone's right
well they can go to atlantic city
they can go to atlantic city okay yeah
yeah we go to connecticut you can also
do it in cities you can also we're
yonkers any place you can gamble for any
indian territory yes indians can abort
yeah yes that's the rule we got a lot of
people we probably don't know
i mean native indians that's they need
population actually they should not be
allowed to abort they just you guys can
get your numbers up they can do it
though i think that's the rule oh native
americans yes that's reparations but you
need more people that's a good point
yeah they shouldn't but they should be
able to abort some white people that's
reparations yes exactly they kill some
wife babies
yeah i mean that's actually
a little payback so that's my solution
that could work
i'm trying to wrap my head around this
i don't like it
why not
i think
women should be allowed to murder their
babies okay i agree this thing is crazy
what
what
isn't that the argument
isn't that really what people are trying
to avoid isn't that the discussion but
yeah it is a baby i do think life begins
at conception it's so dope being a guy
because every dude because even every
dude is basically like yeah women y'all
should be able to kill that [ __ ] but
like we don't have to bear the
consequences of it at all so it's easy
for us to be like you deserve the rights
but we do nothing that's a good joke
it's great it's a great joke
infamous
dot com you can buy uh just clip up on
youtube you know this is what we do
that's what you can do when you own your
special when you buy back do you know
what i'm saying
free speech free speech um
but yeah it's just great being like a
guy it really is
i understand why women want to be guys
now yeah yeah
i get that the other way around is a
little weird
right well you probably don't have to
worry about the abortion
so it's got thing
best of both worlds a little bit yeah
that's it yeah whoa
whoa
yeah i mean take it from me it's it's
pretty good oh are you a girl now i'm
transitioning slowly
are you making fun of my culture
this is my culture too are you making a
mockery of my culture my culture you're
like two percent 14 14 percent of here i
did it 23 23.
between me
it's
a season that's gaelic okay that's what
he pronounced it in my culture i'm
scottish say what i'm scottish 14 14
and then what majority french i don't
trust that 23andme [ __ ] at all
they'd just be throwing [ __ ] around no
it's accurate
because not if you took it you'd be like
13 percent [ __ ] canadian or something
they just not alphas get the privilege
of knowing over from akash okay some
people like us had our cultures ripped
from us
and now we have to figure it out what
does it mean to be french yeah
how do they know that you're from that
region what's specific to that region
what kind of white you are bro it's my
culture okay so i can get in touch with
you but your dna is not your culture
yeah it is though no now now it is also
hold on one second
here hit the d 23.
so no no
also
23andme
what does it really prove how does it
prove that you're french i don't even
understand what that means
just the genes of people from that
region what do you mean how do they
trace all that back why doesn't it why
does it stop
400 years ago like how do they know when
to stop it myself because mesopotamia
100 mesopotamian bro let's go exactly
yeah i thought that all humans are from
africa then to r23 and me should be in
africa how do they get the technology to
stop conveniently where white people are
born
right
that's pretty good i'm just saying
this specific 23andme technology stops
300 years ago it just stops it shouldn't
hustle y'all
[Music]
okay it wasn't me that did it who did it
my sister she's 23 and meet herself yeah
so that doesn't you don't know if your
mom was catching
you could do second second i'll point
that thing exactly click click 23 and
she that's you guys there's no [ __ ]
accuracy there yeah that's 14 scottish
that's nonsense
[Laughter]
here thank you dead in the middle of
little italy my boy
but anyway rover is waiting all the time
because we are in little italy and he
was dead in that
[Laughter]
jungle there's a lot of things that
lined up for that big fun line to just
crack like that it's mad funny where you
got to explain it bad funny guy
717 speech okay save all that abortion
money use it on my website
yeah have a kid and a special boom facts
yeah facts all right okay go so this is
what we said if uh if roe versus wade
was gonna be overturned this is what you
agreed to okay well hey watch watch
watch watch what
is people talking what happens if it
gets overturned what are you willing to
do
i will
oh boy do a um oh boy do you have any
memory of them no
oh boy
like a video where it's i'm on one side
and then the the the kid living the
lifestyle
that is he's on the other side and i'll
do the duet with him i'll do it do it
okay i'll do it
all right
yep it's that time oh god everybody load
to your words
all right let's go gotta look right into
this can okay but i need to time it with
him all right you wanna get one drive
run and then and then you can go for it
is he also wearing a pearl necklace
okay
okay okay
timing down real quick no no i got it
you want to hit it all right you tell me
give me a little countdown
[Music]
let's go give me countdown go ahead go
start it up terry three two one go
[Music]
excited to stay super excited bro